[Music]
we have some developed now called
technicians theorem the pinyon de francy
version okras in the Commission son
appears a vocalist a Parisian Shantha
these three Polish workers are what we
call posted workers who leave their home
countries to work on temporary
assignments abroad their number in the
EU has increased from 600,000 in 2007 to
two point zero five million in 2015 they
work as bricklayers in Germany as
plumbers in France or like elidio
Ferreira from Portugal as construction
workers in Belgium topic a family firm
on television
something favelas in pronounceable for
some folks wonderful color difference
I keep resemblance to this booth in 2014
sakaki-kun amended a higher salary
that's what attracts posted workers but
for the same work they are generally
paid less than local workers who lead on
the controller from that materia
look-look ultimate fear a PLC at the
flexibility no affair with a possibly
from that these do travel some d-iii
affiliate the wage difference is at the
heart of the revision of the 1996 law on
the posting of workers which the
European Parliament is working on
lubricants in the ship sea in memory
mini resume who are mentally johan men
youth the turbine for me it's very
important that in the future we don't
have first and second class workers in
europe ending wage dumping ending unfair
competition
ending exploitation of workers
it's a difficult task because the
interests of the member states differ
widely in fact the countries that
receive the highest number of posted
workers are also the ones sending a lot
of their own workers abroad and some
countries fear losing an important labor
market in this polish agency for posted
workers there are hundreds of requests
every day French German and Polish
companies are looking for highly skilled
workers
Moin stallion medic fever of particle
disappointed petitioner he needs me as
many if you caught you also saw the food
Samantha Gordon poor miss me - [ __ ] -
judicial opinions prasat neak of our
economy scheme America Frances cream
uranium kopalski
Emami purchasing atomic la fille de
acción eva chemo midi new some solution
definitely Karla Antoine will never fit
compete on less than four months is the
average length of a posting in the
European Union the European Parliament
however has not shut the door to longer
postings the growing demand for posted
workers goes along with an increase in
fraud undeclared employees salaries
letter below minimum wage or the use of
letterbox companies letterbox companies
send workers to work in another country
while the headquarters are located in a
third country where they have no actual
business activities but benefit from
lower social contributions the present
rules dates from past century so they're
from 96 I think when we are making the
rules more clear again it's also clear
what is fair and what is thought
facilitating the movement of European
workers while better protecting their
rights is crucial to building the
foundations of a social Europe that is
the objective of the revision of the
directive on posted workers
you
[Music]